rien de mieux qu'un bain de soleil pour
se calmer l'esprit sans oublier de vous
enduire de crème solaire bien sûr un
moment d'apaisement possible grâce et
surtout à une couche d'ozone sans trou
et bonne nouvelle les scientifiques
estiment que cette couche protectrice
autrefois affaiblie est en voie de
rétablissement d'ici 40 ans un accord
international visant à protéger la
couche d'ozone sera vraisemblablement
signée à Montréal on doit ses résultats
positifs au Protocole de Montréal signé
en 1987 et ratifié par 198 pays un
accord interdisant l'utilisation de
produits chimiques nocifs pour
l'atmosphère les chloraux fluoro
carbures notamment appelé les CFC que
l'on retrouvait partout comme
réfrigérant comme propulseur dans les
aérosols et dans les emballages mais les
substituts au CFC se sont révélés
d'importants contributeurs au
réchauffement climatique on a largement
résolu le problème de la couche d'ozone
stratosphérique mais quelque part à
cause des émissions de la base
industrielle on a aggravé le problème du
réchauffement du climat
c'est l'amendement de Kigali signé en
2016 qui est venu rectifier le tir tous
ces efforts concertés ont aussi permis
de ralentir les changements climatiques
si les scientifiques saluent ces
résultats ils mettent toutefois en garde
contre le génie humain notamment une
technique expérimentale qui atténue les
rayonnements du soleil l'équivalent de
l'effet produit par l'éruption
volcanique du Pinatubo aux Philippines
en 1991 on avait alors observé une
baisse de la température de 1 degré et
ces aérosols ont effectivement la
capacité de de rejeter une partie du
rayonnement solaire vers l'espace et
donc de diminuer la puissance du
chauffage solaire
à l'échelle de l'ensemble de la planète
des technologies qui en sont encore à
leur balbutiements mais qui selon
l'Organisation météorologique mondiale
pourrait perturber la couche d'ozone à
peine rétabli ici Elisa serrer
Radio-Canada Montréal